[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
oh hello happy tuesday we hope you're
blown out too it's the break room uh
it's our daily live show that keeps you
updated on all the nerdy fandom news you
need to know
welcome back uh we're so happy you're
here we got a great show coming up today
uh uh
we echo the echo trailer reveals that
kingpin always sleeps with one eye open
uh keenan and brendan frazier feel some
type of way about batgirl it's tom
hiddle out there playing us like a
fiddle uh and releasing some info on
loki season two
uh don't tell my wife but we're all
asking for jessica's hand in marriage
true much like the targans i will take a
second wife that's right that's right
that's right what is he calling my
bronze
uh
i got a lovely wife at home but i'll
make jessica my bronze [ __ ] you know
what all right
i'm brandon i'm causing problems
everywhere but across the table for me
we got tom michaelson hey how's it going
guys i'm also here i i'm married but i'm
also here to ask for jesse's hand so
sorry honey if you're watching this live
it's going it's going down today we're
going down today and of course we got
the targaryen princess herself jessica
clement
a lot of you guys are acting like i'm
going to say yes to everybody we're just
holding i haven't heard our pictures yet
you got a dream
i'm willing to hear it i'm trying to be
the change i want to see in the world uh
uh next me my boy tommy back to a baby
what's up it's tommy with two m's and
one y but not where you think it is
and behind tommy of course you can see a
lovely redemption wheel what's that some
animals on it why could that be animal
cells are we making animals
i'll do that for free
but for every hundred dollars we raised
this super chat see if it was an outfit
we're gonna have our faces painted uh
we're acting like it's philip's birthday
everyone know that phil molina loves
face painting he demanded we do it on
his birthday uh it's on his birthday
today thank goodness uh but we are doing
face paints today for every hundred
dollars we raised in super chats uh so
certainly send in those super chats we
do love them uh we love all your
questions we love hearing from you out
there in the wide chat world uh so help
us get our faces painted but before we
just get those faces painted what are
you basic paint your face are you poor
or something come on
everyone i know has a painted face it's
just the banks don't worry about it the
banks won't let me paint my fights
speaking of painted faces let's get to
the headline
oh thank you for that drum roll that was
beautiful
first headline olivia coleman's secret
invasion character has been confirmed to
be sonia falsworth uh an alleged old
friend of nick fury and a relative of
the fallsworth that was in the howling
commandos of the devin show of the
jeffershire falsewood serving in the
holland commandos my father was a
howling commander oh was he i am howling
commando my son's a howling commando we
falsely have been howling commandos for
two centuries now two centuries wait is
this your pitch to marriage wait we're
not doing that
otherwise i'm about to
we've been speculating for a while that
she's playing this character falls worth
and it was kind of out there but they
did confirm it in their uh press
the media stuff they put out from d23
this photo said she is playing sonia
falls worth uh a friend of nick fury's
but it is interesting to see the
relation she's been fighting hydra since
she's just strong
oh she's tommy calling it more like
sonya skrullsworth
hang on give me more like sonia
oh that that that came off better it's
interesting because i feel like i mean i
was expecting val to maybe come in and
play that role a little bit in terms of
being an old friend of nick fury's and
maybe tying in she still might show up
at secret watch out he's friends with
val and val's just like i hate her
right val
she's a scrawl
for everyone
that's going to be a long long season of
pointing fingers and positions oh my
goodness oh my goodness in the end the
skrulls were the friends we made along
the way okay that's true i don't like
that one it's beautiful next headline uh
the echo trailer revealed kingpin's fate
at the end of hawkeye uh d23 they gave
us a little sneak peek of the echo
series very cool a lot of like jumping
through time seeing uh the echoes across
generations you know
a little play on words there
yeah yeah very good stuff uh but at the
end of the footage they show kingpin
like kind of comes out from behind the
garden shed uh and he's alive which we
assumed that he would be alive since
he's getting a series yeah with
daredevil we knew he'd be in the show
but it's not just flashbacks uh it is
forward
flash forward flash forwards forward
looks current state uh he has like a
little makeshift eye patch on uh like
the kind you get from urgent care it
wasn't like a cool ipad
thing yeah it's like you like i think we
said the other day when you walk into a
tree branch and they're like oh we gotta
put something over that to make sure it
doesn't get infected does he have a
band-aid uh uh does he have like
advanced healing i know he's strong no i
don't think so but he's not a mutant
right i think he's not knowing he's just
strong just like strong human he seems
to be like a prime candidate for at some
point in that daredevil season for some
like doctor to be like i i tinker with
chitauri tech and i've made an eyeball
like oh yeah you're like i'm like
and he'll be like i have a
bionic eye now maybe there's i'm trying
to think of like what spider-man
villains have not been introduced to
other daredevil you know those like new
york villains that are like doctors that
do uh the tinker with stuff the tinkerer
there you go
but it's yeah so does he have the patch
because the gun went next to his face or
because if it went into his eye wouldn't
it hit his brain
and it must have gone
yeah that's a good point because we
don't know yeah we it was off screen the
shot was off screen so did it was it
just like a warning next to him like
hurt his hair in his eye yeah we'll sign
out maybe we won't who knows maybe i
hope he's still eating spinach and egg
white envelopes that's all i care about
every morning eating those damn
omelettes
next headline jim starling the creator
of thanos uh has been doing some
interviews and he's been talking about
like seeing thanos again in the mcu uh
he mentioned it in regards to there
being a movie with eros and without
thanos and he said quote i think they're
planning on starting them off without
thanos when you talk about arrows but he
also kind of mentioned that you know
thanos uh makes money for disney and
they don't have money
and he's like a big character and he was
kind of saying like he's disappointed
that there it wasn't more of them in the
mcu before he was kind of taken away
from us because we don't really saw him
at the end of movies and then he shows
up like sitting down in a chair for like
a few minutes at a time and then two
movies i think he plays a big role in
end game but not as much uh yeah so we
could talk to him again the interview is
really funny because he does not hold
back no no no straight up like
he's basically like yeah my contract i
got half the money but they uh went
another direction for a long time and i
don't think i got compensated well for
that like basically yeah the toys that
came the rides everything at marvel like
at marvel campuses the gauntlets he's
like yeah i don't see that money but i
see the money from the movie yeah well
speaking of uh the rides right at d23
they announced an expansion to avengers
campus uh here at disneyland resort and
they're going to be a new ride featuring
a king thanos
scepter
clearly like the brolin model it's not
it's not a variant of thanos that
doesn't look like the one we know right
right right uh and we've seen thanos pop
up and what if season one i'm sure we
could see him in what if season two
and you know down the road it would be
fun to have him come back we're about to
have this multiversal war i don't see
why thanos couldn't show up again so i
wonder if that's what he's talking about
maybe the ride because also the ride is
multiverse too yeah you saw the poster
they got all these characters from all
over the multiverse we gotta have him
back i i don't think i think we gotta
have more than yeah yeah
whatever yeah and i like seeing him in
what if when he was like he's grabbing
the version yeah yeah he was like a fun
fan though yeah yeah
charlotte was right you have to kill
everybody yeah we saw him there we saw
him like try and take on ultron vision
and just
immediately kill him great stuff great i
call him funos
when he's like that you know what i
think thanos is what a scroll yes
welcome aboard
would you like to be so funny if someone
does a scroll is like i'm thanos and
it's like we haven't seen that man in a
long time and they're like oh [ __ ] i
didn't get my things coined oh yeah he's
like wait that was just dead dammit
they come in as like ronin and it's like
wait no oh god there was that theory
that like uh our tony stark was a thanos
or a skrull the whole time and so that
they could bring back robert jenny
junior but beyonce
but that's like an implied that like a
skrull like impregnated pepper yeah
also was like the most was also what was
the most heroic did the snap
was like right he's like i'm really
living this gimmick man i gotta die for
you that would have been epic if at the
end of end game he goes and i am
a scroll dude
that would have been nuts
that was a squirrel yeah no i don't know
i would love to see thanos again i think
it would be great uh especially josh
mullen he was so good at that next
headline tom hiddleston uh
teased teased some memory of some
mysteries from loki season two uh he was
talking about how like season one
finishes with loki arriving back at the
tva after a very distressing
confrontation uh with sylvie and he
remains uh and he has a whole bunch of
questions that need answers uh and then
this was at d23 where owen wilson was
too and he mentioned it was like that
talking head song this is not my
beautiful life how did i get here uh so
it's like loki's coming back he's back
at the tva uh
there's a cool thing in the footage they
showed where there was like a mural of
the time keepers and he hit the little
like wand uh the little time baton
against and it dissipated and you saw
like kang's faces behind it so i i just
hope they don't spend too much time kind
of rehashing
season one yeah with the like getting to
know everybody
i want that
the whole arc of the whole season is
just them being friends again that's
going to be rough yeah yeah yeah i want
them to get i think i need to see more
press with owen wilson where he just
goes to like 1980s he cuts about like
not being like only in my dreams and
stuff he just constantly references
talking songs he's like there was a
super [ __ ] song once upon a time in
your wildest dreams
yeah yeah if you're a big fan of 70s
rock please call it let us know some of
your ladies rock next headline uh we got
an update uh or a confirmation of monica
rambo's powers uh that we're going to
see in the marvels it's been confirmed
that she can fly
yes she can fly she can fly she can fly
up up and away
just like in the comments she can't find
the comics she didn't fly on juan
division she tried to she wanted to do
so bad uh did she do like a superhero
landing yeah she did like a little
landing uh yeah yeah but like she's
gotta it's been confirmed that she will
fight we of course saw her her mother
from another dimension
flying uh
in in a multiverse of my life yeah
because she was captain marvel in that
in that universe but it's good to see
that she can fly uh we were i was joking
earlier that i can't wait for the scene
where
uh
danvers and monica like take off and
kamala's left standing in there like
she gets like nine feet tall she's like
yeah you guys i'll meet you there i'll
meet you there she's running all night
like
please
please no
this is very hard for me oh she'll make
those little steps be like think
twinkling and just climb like just tying
up a ladder the whole time it hurts is
just pure endurance yeah yeah you're
right yeah right hard stuff that's
that's a lot
i want to point out 838 captain marvel
to me is the only possible alive member
of the illuminati
oh yeah yeah this time for sure
like if she has the same powers as brie
larson's captain marvel in 616 she's not
dead
yeah but you don't know statues in that
dimension could be five thousand
this
uh we ran a paul in the chat asking uh
who you guys think won't survive loki
season two they got to kill off somebody
i think 37 said ravona rinslayer but
mopius also had 31 percent
sylvia 26 loki at four
no i guess they're not gonna kill loki
again i think they're gonna kill mobius
well they kind of tried to they tried to
kill him in the first one when we
thought he got like perched or whatever
yeah they already and then loki too they
already kind of pulled the rug out from
under us with both of those
would be interesting i mean eric eric
has kind of the theory about what kang
is you know trying to get scotland to
heist for him yeah uh isaiah man his
theory was that it's not a thing it's a
person it's ravona right like he wants
to get her back yeah yeah
uh i i don't know it would be
interesting i i we'll see if they kill
someone off that mobius oh my poor
mobius you can't kill moebius you've
already scared us once you can kill him
he's fine
speaking of killing off heroes we got
some more uh
thoughts on batgirl uh uh the emmys were
last night if you didn't see it uh and
uh uh my uh keaton michael keane was
asked about his role in batgirl and it
being canceled uh and a very keen
fashion he said quote i think it was a
business business decision and i'm going
to assume it was a good one he also
added i really don't know which is very
michael keaton anytime they ask you
about any of these superheroes
i'll pull out that photo pull that photo
together a photo of him
at the end he had a great time wanting
at me last night for his work on doses
very good very good special if you
didn't see it limited series uh but
that's a very like keem hasn't he said
he hasn't watched any yeah he says he's
like never watched his the marvel yeah
of all time
[ __ ] people who say they don't watch
their stuff they watch it in private and
it makes them uncomfortable maybe yeah
or when you go to the premiere you're
still watching it oh yeah i didn't
deserve people sitting in the premiere
though yeah yeah they walked away they
sit down the lights go down and they
head out there maybe he came for the end
credits of morbius and saw that he's
like someone get eyes on keaton if
you're watching this movie someone make
him watch them yeah
if you're out there and you're watching
right now we would love for you to come
on the show
check your inbox we're gonna be emailing
you soon yeah let us know if michael
keaton watches the movies we know you
hang out with the kids oh yeah we know
you guys are tight yeah you guys are
tight uh but they also
asked brendan frazier about bad girl he
he had an interview and variety talking
about his role in the upcoming from the
whale uh directed by darren aronofsky uh
he's already winning awards for it could
this be his year to get an oscar the
fraser stance is upon us uh but he had a
lot more to say about batgirl he said
quote it's disappointing the fans really
wanted to see this film made i was there
leslie grace is a dynamo she's like a
power q-tip which i don't really get
that one but i don't know wait wait okay
it might fit into more of the interview
i don't know but she's like a power
q-tip she just goes for it she looks
great in the outfit the movie itself was
sean conceived for a smaller screen in
this age we've come out of uh
we've come out of between streaming
service versus theatrical release it
wound up being the
canary in the coal mine so what can we
learn from this work with trusted
filmmakers like derek whoa that's some
good pr phrase well he said what he's
saying there is like when it comes to
making these movies you shouldn't let
like a streaming service decide what's
best for the movie it shouldn't be made
for streaming it should be made for
movie theaters it should be
uh done by a trusted director
he's also he's promoting his like film
the whale and he's not saying anything
bad about the directors of background
right but after he got done with that he
got a 13-minute standing ovation yes he
did they finished that quote and they
were like perfectly sad anyway
is warner brothers the dirty ear that
needs the power yeah yeah they need the
power
by the way
anyone who's ever been to west hollywood
knows you can get power q-tips for
65 bucks and they're life-changing
they're life-changing
yeah yeah he's basically saying like it
was a good movie i mean i was working
hard it was looking great but like don't
let these decisions be made by the
streaming services right right i want to
be made by the directors but who's
paying for it the streaming services
who's paying for it us
exactly we all paid for this movie we
want to see it we want to see it that's
right uh next headline and it's an
important headline folks have you
checked your netflix have you checked
the top ten well what's in there it's
morbid time morbius is dominating wow
dominating
people are so busy watching the show
they're not buying the mug
that's right if you're new to the show
we recently had a mug contest this mug
no longer available and he's not even
here he deserves it we begged him to be
here he refused bigger than zach this is
bigger than this this isn't zach's
failure
this is now not available not available
in the shop anymore is this morbid time
mug but you can't get a mandatory you
can get this mug forever it won it won't
by the way i have the list of all of you
that got the morbid type mugs i will be
coming to your house and slapping your
ground oh boy
you can't say that i can't no i just
can't say that okay
when we run this
[Applause]
right now if you want to see one of
these beautiful facades they painted
like an animal i don't want they don't
want us to look cool
they hate fun they like raccoons and
dumpsters we've already gotten some
super chats the ivory said how soon
until you think we'll see a loki season
two trailer much love in our fam i don't
think they'll put it out before
uh secret invasion that's our next
series right i think towards the end of
secret invasion is when they'll start
promoting loki i don't is there a series
before loki
is next summer what if we'll maybe come
out in the spring echo is also 20. that
goes yeah yeah yeah it feels like we're
going to get a log jam right now because
nothing is guaranteed before
february or march right now though we're
assuming secret invasion is going to
move up or be put like somewhere in
january somewhere earlier because
otherwise then all we have is werewolf
by night and then
just a quiet
quarter of the year which we can't
handle here yeah we need we need busy we
need discussion we need to like to do
like either an end of the year kind of
beginning of the year here's what's
coming in 2023 yeah we could see a
little bit there man we're gonna be
breaking down young sheldon if we're not
getting oh boy don't force tommy to
break down young sheldon
strings he didn't notice yeah
it all ties into the big bang there's
lots of there's lots of stuff to break
down next year maybe yellow jackets yeah
season two
heads up we'd love to guys want us to
break stuff down
and talk about it on the break room
though you have to hit us up on social
speaking yeah hit us up on our retail
twitter people don't believe us we got
to show them the data we got to show
them the reach so you want to cover
yellow jackets we'd love to cover the
yellow jackets yeah we'd be thrilled too
i've got lots of fairies yeah i wanna
cover barry season five or whatever
we'll cover barry you gotta let him know
i'll do the new avatar the new avatar
movie yeah okay we might i'll be going
to see the new avatar together or the
old one the old adventure i gotta i
gotta forget everything avatar movies
our lovely chat uh would you see would
you use morbius to netflix and chill uh
52 said no
47 said yes i'm missing one percent
somewhere
how could you not turn that on that's a
great netflix and chill movie oh
because you start it and then
immediately your partner is like i would
like to move on the second second yes
exactly the second man who's never
walked a clean step in his life jumps
off a ship from like 8 000 feet into the
water and swims to shore you're like
probably didn't they say they found that
ship like 30 miles off the street yeah
like that you swear them 30 miles
they're like we should probably just
start looking up right now
on the internet that's like yeah you
have sex to the beat of music could you
imagine having sex with a beat of
morbius the opening credits i like that
one song that's like
someone also put the emoji a punch in
your grandma we said slap yes
grandma's here okay hello we're
definitely not doing this
awesome okay okay uh trash bag sending
in a super chat who's mug one hashtag
team morphin time unfortunately tommy's
mug one yeah unfortunately yeah i'm team
morphin time the sales speak for
themselves it was a blowout well it's
because the team morgan time people are
too busy we're watching morbius watching
morbius donating their money to save
children you know what i mean that's
right
fun
bunch they just dumpster dove for little
treasures they refurbished old chairs
they sold them at swap meets and they
bought their mugs on their free wi-fi
from a cafe or a library
seo panther also sending in a super chat
838 illuminati is alive the entire fight
was a perfect professor x mine
simulation
thunder
so he's like i'm going to mind simulate
myself getting killed from here yeah
the only the only one hurt in the 838
was pizza pop unfortunately yeah that's
true but he always gets paid every time
s z o panther super chat i think i i'm
not looking at the board and you read it
i think you're saying s-e-o uh panther
it's search engine optimization yeah
yeah
yeah
it's trending on this guy our girl loves
to be high up on the google search
exactly miss panther right here it's joe
you guys ready for my break room
breakdown yeah i think it's just a thumb
but you can play it let's do it
we can call it a break room breakdown
sure let's break it down you guys at d23
during the marvel panel when kevin feige
is making the transition from talking
about captain america new world order to
discussing thunderbolts he said you know
one thing in the captain america film is
that there currently is a world without
the avengers sam wilson finds himself as
uh as cap at a time where there's not an
organizat an organization for the
avengers uh
okay
so avengers don't exist which i think we
kind of already assumed because it's
like they're all spreading out they're
all becoming dads or dying
the two worst d's
um so it's like
it's like they're all kind of
evaporating themselves and we're getting
um now the thunderbolts we're talking so
much about young avengers don't know how
quick it's gonna happen but it's like
why okay so why or no let's start with
where are the current avengers right now
where do we know we know hulk just went
off to another car which is uh in hell
yeah which is in hell quicksilver is
also dead yeah yeah yeah the core the
chorus
hulk is off world tough world where's
thor thor is off world of fighting other
aliens yeah
with his life
captain america steve rogers
so basically it's white vision and
hawkeye out there somewhere oh yeah guys
around retired again he's around but
he's like come back guys come on like
four times yeah yeah originals it's
basically hawkeye is the one that he's
the only one like on earth
and of an age to continue being but with
everyone has their own uh you know
person to succeed them you know like
elena being the new black widow she hulk
being maybe the new hulk
other than you know and jade thor's and
valhalla we don't know if she's coming
back but she could be the new thor there
might be there's a pipeline for them
coming back i think that's the question
of like since we have the young avengers
that we're talking about so much we
don't know where they're coming we have
the mutants coming for x-men maybe
possibly and then we have uh the
thunderbolts it's like why haven't they
why did it take till now to make a new
team
it does seem odd that like the dod the
dodc and sword right they are the
government organizations that we know of
and originally
the avengers were a government team
right they were part of shield shield
gets dissolved and then they became
private tony was paying for them
basically
uh but now you have a situation where
yeah why hasn't the government
they know the threats out there right
you got like thanos level threats you
got the crees and the skrulls out there
you've got
giant uh celestials living inside your
planet right you have all these things
you would think the government would
have someone and the sokovia accords
kind of just went away because yeah you
know they still exist yes right and it
seems like that's going to become a
bigger thing soon it's about to ramp up
a little bit more back
and roadies around right he's around
he's around oh yeah i forgot about
rhodey and brodie's the business
the dodc has confiscated all of stark
tech or a lot of it yeah right so they
could just be empowering their own
military with higher technology we saw
the dodc rolled up with against the
teenager
mosque they had the killer drones they
had killer drones yeah they had sound
cannon machines if we were to make a new
avengers and i'm talking like i'm not
saying
dark avengers thunderbolts i'm saying if
they were literally like okay our
avengers are all dead or dads how this
is our avengers team now right so who
would who would be in charge of that
yes the cap's got to be in charge i
would think well no i meant like because
iron man was giving them the money oh
you mean like
yeah
maybe wakanda and the new black panther
with all that kind of money and cause
also that was another thing it was great
but it was kind of convenient in falcon
winter soldier where they're like also
here's your vibranium wakandan suit that
will work perfectly for you and maybe
that's how they'll start furnishing the
rest of the team like
you know maybe that's how they'll do it
they'll give them upgrades because
that's an endless that's like bruce
wayne money yeah
also i mean like are we go i mean is
there i know this is like kind of like
you know
procedural but like is there a chance
that
tony set up some trust funds for the
avengers i think so well that's where's
pepper right pepper is in charge of
stark industries she's a mom not a dad
but she's a mom oh yes she can still
survive but the rest of them are all
dead yeah the thing about what i want
which we'll probably get eventually into
talking about pepper is like did his
assets actually get liquidated that's
what i'm really stuck on is what
happened to all the dark industries the
stark industry still exists yeah because
watch her be like i don't want to be
involved in my dead husband's affairs
anymore i'm sure she's like i'm tired
yeah i just want to be with my daughter
during this trying times yes and he's
unprecedented yeah well what do we make
of this scene the post-credits scene in
shanghai then when wang is talking with
captain marvel and bruce
that's not an official avengers thing i
guess that is just like uh just like
we're tapping the minds of the yeah yeah
like the smartest people they can about
well that's the thing
is gonna not
full-heartedly what is vaughn creates
the new avengers team by just reaching
out to the avengers that he's met and
he's just like
he is the sorcerer's surprise i'm just
saying i'm just saying doctor strange is
off world you know uh that's right he's
just he's chasing strange another
dimension yeah chasing strangers
the lady showed up on the street cut a
hole in the universe and he said i'm in
let's go look at schweins
yeah he didn't even lock his front door
he didn't like no leave a message for
anybody nope he's just like i'm out of
here sorry wong you're on your own i
mean i think this is this discussion is
the kind of perfect microcosm of like
the fact that all of these phase four
projects have kind of been like
blowing this universe out putting
everybody so far away and now like a
vacuum it's all going to get sucked back
in we're going to be reminded of why
that ending of shanghai matters why the
sokovia courts matter it's all coming
back and it's up to us to put the puzzle
pieces together here on new rockstar's
break room
where we're going to bring it here first
folks well you say bringing it all back
together do you think any original
members
of the the core six that are still alive
four six of the avengers could come back
to a new avengers team do you see any of
them coming in we're talking about we
are talking the core he's like
pretty much hot guys
hawkeye maybe vision if you want to
include him as uh he's not original he's
not original i could see hulk and thor
yeah are the two that i could see making
the most not just because they're alive
but because their stories also show them
they're still fighting crime they're
still out there without korea reaches
out to thor i was like we need your
background just by frost back he'd bring
his daughter oh yeah
and she joined the team and she would
train most definitely i think yeah i
think
well it sucks because it's like yeah it
has to be those two because those are
the only two hawkeye could technically
cut he came out of retirement before he
could come out of retirement again so
it's like yeah the ones that are awake
could come back it's more so it's like
i don't i think hulk wouldn't i think we
can't reach him if he's going to be off
world and he's not a car again or
somewhere else i don't know he had a
phone service for that uh a little bit
yeah that's true
so we already know that we're getting
the thunderbolts with a fun fun team
yeah then we didn't really get a hint of
any of the young avengers and i know a
lot of people are pitching like young
avengers and dark avengers were kind of
blend to make the thunderbolts for some
reason so what uh are the different
variations of avengers based teams we
could look forward to in the future now
well
you even set it up when you started this
jessica how he was he fighty was saying
this in the transition to thunderbolts
right yeah almost saying like the
thunderbolts are going to be like our
team of avengers that is just going to
be our but they're also weird because we
know that like they're more on the shady
side they're supposed to be more like
special ops and a lot of the members of
the team are like former soldiers whose
most power is like fighting and straight
or being similar to cap like yeah you're
having taskmaster and then red guardian
i
love
love the red guardian but you can't tell
me that that character is going to be
the new on the new avengers right like
you know what i mean
like putting bucky on that team where he
you know he's got his beef he's got his
beef with yeah yeah my well the issue i
also have is like when i say
our avengers based team i'm talking
about like how avengers had three movies
yeah they had a bunch of movies so
thunderbolts is just thunderbolts right
now and we know there's two avengers
movies coming up well are they gonna be
the avengers for that i was thinking
that they might you know what they could
do is they could try to divvy people up
based on skill set in the sense of like
here's some street level teams with
daredevil here's echo you know i mean
you could even throw in you know iron
heart if you want and then here's some
magic based teams you know with like
chung chi and uh you know like uh maybe
even
black panther could fit in there both
those teams and they might split up in
that way kind of in the way where
infinity war end game for the most part
the teams were just just by circumstance
were kind of split up to take on
different things like here's a group
taking on thanos on i like titan and
stuff and so maybe they're they're going
to have whatever the new thread is with
the kangs they're going to have to divvy
up in that way in terms of what their
skill set is could be kind of hard to
again have an archer versus some
galactus
with the ten rings is you know fighting
the kingpin uh maybe put hawkeye on that
one and you go take on galactus you know
i like the idea of uh splitting up the
teams it just seems like i would be so
mad to be given the thunderbolts and
then be like but during the avengers we
were only going to use two of these
people yeah yeah i just wish there was
someone other than just punching people
on the thunderbolts you know like i
think i think that team's not done yet
yeah
i don't think so either i think also
because everyone keeps being like
where's nemo i'm like i think baron zemo
is gonna yeah he's gonna come in like
this
he's gonna come in when val gets killed
oh
he's gonna take over and that's when the
team splits up into like who wants to
stay and who wants to go
no problem uh i think that uh you know
we can remember that fantastic four
although it is the you know the original
lineup is obviously you know mr
fantastic the invisible woman the thing
and the human torch oftentimes other
people sub in on that team we have
spiderman has been fantastic
has been the fantastic
they could use the fantastic four as a
jumping off point of a new team as well
and maybe it becomes a fantastic
40. yeah maybe yeah fantastic fantastic
i like the idea of also using one member
of the fantastic four to lead the
avengers whether it be um
reed richards or someone else but that'd
be fun that would be fun
last but not least sorry
no we know the answer to this uh sorry i
wrote this question myself will we get
another avengers like team up yeah we
are for sure for sure
at least two i hope there's a march
madness style uh round-robin tournament
where several different teams form
themselves they get together like you
want to be on team yeah and they're like
where the avengers know we're the
avengers they're gonna fight that'll be
great yeah that's too different from us
we've got student hockey pads
we asked you guys in the chat uh will
any original avengers return for our new
avengers team up 68 said yes i saw a lot
of defending of hawkeye in there they do
not like our hot guys
and also uh
where are the defenders
and
the defenders i hate to say this you
guys we're not gonna see them for a
minute i don't know if we do when they
do come in watch them like treat them
like the wrecking group and i'm gonna be
like hey there's three people there's
street level they're the defenders
hey
is just throwing red flags up in the
chat red flags well we are gonna be
painting some faces it looks like tommy
and i are going to be getting our faces
painted you want to speak for sure
smackaboom
be careful with what booze you smack
thank you for your huge super chat
sending in a whole hundred dollars for a
w uh go ahead and roll tommy let's see
what you get here
what [ __ ] oh
very close to bobby but he landed on fox
i like did you have the pictures up here
also to help me because i'm like i think
i remember that's what a fox looks like
yeah jessica will get started on that
fox for tammy uh thank you to our other
super chatters the
mj2997 sending in a super chat saying i
ain't spending 130
for a monday motivational on tuesday
brother i hear you i hear you out there
it's fair uh smackdown is also saying
love you guys uh seo panther not seo
panther yeah saying civil war two wong
versus fury
that would be a good idea
i'd have to take one side on that one
thank you joe he's got that like whip
thank you dj cold cuts just saying cold
cuts
uh
hawkeye
he's definitely no that's right mj oh
that's right he most certainly is hannah
asking for percy jackson content dude
yeah i can do oh i love percy jackson i
tweeted at them and i was like i was
like cast me in the new percy jackson
and two maybe we're like she's too old
dang cold blooded i would like to see
yeah this is me also standing in a super
chat saying in honor of roger's the
musical please write and perform a break
room musical zac you can kill off film
juice i mean that's it that's the ending
right there i can keep them all dead
i think that sounds like a great idea to
write a whole entire musical
and kaijo wren saying my number one
suspect for the scroll search mystique
that's a tough one
plus oh is it really a skrull is it
mystique
it's like the chicken in the egg who
came first because there's a
shape-shifting left and right uh jelly
bean sent in a super chat saying what do
you guys think of my ridiculous idea
that king and quantomanium isn't the
main kang it might die at the end of the
film and then we'll be replaced by
another some might know i just want to
see more kings jellybean i think you're
on the money no no i think that i don't
think that's done at all i think the
movies will be just killing kang yeah
and they keep coming i think
and quantomania get the upper hand it'll
look like the end is nigh and then
another king will just stab him right in
the back and the worst k will show up
exactly yeah yeah you thought that thing
was bad yeah way to see this why do you
see where did that you know what they're
going to load to me
uh while tommy gets his fox work done
and i prepare to get my own face painted
i i think about i would we'd like to
take a moment to thank our sponsors over
at better health because i think about
like the masks we wear and the way we
paint our face
a lot of times it's tough out there we
want to keep our minds healthy we want
to keep our minds happy we want to be
happy we want to be ourselves uh and a
good way to like find that happiness is
through therapy uh but maybe you don't
want to leave your house to do therapy
thankfully our friends that better help
offer online therapy solutions uh i've
had therapy before in the past i think
it's great i think if you're interested
in it you should certainly explore it
never feel shameful that kind of stuff
uh it's tough out there we're just dumb
apes living in mental health is so
important yeah yeah we're supposed to be
hunter gatherers and we're living in
this crazy society
and there's all these expectations and
we're aware of our immortality it's
tough there's a lot to think about but
therapy is a great way uh to kind of
express those ideas and work through
them and think about it so you can sleep
well at night uh better help is online
therapy a lot of people around here have
used it tommy has used it look at this
beautiful workout
i've knocked that out so fast i've got a
lot of things going on for me people
like me oh it matches your red beard and
everything oh so i'm what's known as a
mover and shaker and a taste maker in
this town but sometimes when i go home
alone to my house where i have no wife
or children i think about the permanence
of things and the decisions i've made to
get here and that's what better help
online you want to finish this while i
get my facebook page really get your
let's paint you up like a doll sweet
cheeks
all right hang on so let me tell you
something i use better health there's no
secret i meet with a wonderful therapist
we talk through all my problems but they
offer video phone and live chat only
therapy sessions do you have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy trust me on that one i paid for
both and you know
sometimes you get what you pay for but
in this case
you save a little few bucks you get a
great therapist okay now here's what's
really nice all right yeah keep me on
three baby so i can read this thing our
listeners get 10 off the first month at
betterhelp.com
break room that's better h-e-l-p
dot-com
break room for 10 off trust the fox man
okay what would the fox say go to
betterhelp.com
[Laughter]
that's right
the foxiest segment no the land
i'm sorry now
we all know if we watched our house of
the dragons and then caught up on
talking dragons here on uh
what's this called again
i was gonna thank you for that plug but
no problem
i was trying to figure out if it
specifically was you know it's the big
question presents there you go you
nailed it nailed it
kissed
you're the coward for typing it in the
chat call my mobile phone you know my
number carlton uh it's not unusual for
carlton to be a little [ __ ] all right
now
we watch our house of the dragons we uh
we know that princess rinera is the most
coveted princess in all of the land for
wifing and strifing so we saw their
speed dating we saw that that was pretty
fun but we have a princess here on the
break room that's princess jessica and
let me tell you she is our princess we
all loved her we'd all do anything for
her we die for jessica if we needed to i
mean i died just as she was bored one
day i laid on the railroad tracks for
her amusement so listen we thought today
princess jessica would entertain
three
uh two married men and one man so
painfully single that it hurts uh
as they close nonetheless oh three
suitors exactly right from their houses
uh so each one of us is going to take a
turn uh pleading our case to jessica tom
do you want to go first sure i can go
first
all right let me get this set up here
from your house okay yeah get yourself
all right so we uh here i'll show off my
my face real fast we have to dress in my
rabbit face
what's up doc this is good
i like that
i'll keep this i'm getting my passport
photo later so this will be great
yeah yeah it'll be great for my password
folks remember that man please wipe that
off is that today
yeah i'm getting a new a new fake
passport today it's gonna be adorable
um i don't know if the people in the
chat remember this when i said it i'll
also take time um okay looks like your
shooters are coming out of here
sorry to interrupt
oh
um may i introduce myself
my name is tom michael stock
i come from the pacific isles
here to request the hand of the maiden
jessica
i am the
wearer of slippers
the eater of crabs
and shall you join my house you shall
have a turtle to ride of your own a
turtle for in my islands we ride turtles
everywhere that sounds slow i ride
you get there eventually
i ride dragon uh blood tooth but you
shall ride
tortellini who i've put aside just for
you
what needs to happen for a turtle when
she has a dragon
you speak like a turtle so slow and
painful i would reply but it will take
me a while to think of a retort
so let me instead say that as you can
see men from the pacific isles are very
beautiful have you heard of
dwayne johnson and jason momoa
they come in third and second i'd like
some more of this to stop so if you will
sir please
jessica if you shall take me you shall
be the most prized jewel in all the
pacific isles
please choose
tom michael stock from house stock give
him the lantern already
thank you m'lady thank you okay i guess
i'll choose at the end
who's next
uh here comes your next one my lady
say oh my
is the little lord beckton he's but a
boy
i'm actually 49 years old but a rare
genetic disability has rendered me tiny
benjamin butterfly get it out i i'm like
my birth certificate says i'm 49. this
is my bird
i love my bird do you love him too
i'm just kidding it's team michael
bechtol
no no
no no as i run things at house beck told
with all 49 of my wives 49 we're looking
for nifty 50 baby i'd be the 50th please
join us in our pleasure dome
the pleasure dog pleasure domes i said
domes plural that implies more than one
okay so we're hard at work on a bobsled
luge bobsledding of course the official
sport of house beck told if you want to
experience nights of ecstasy that
traveler magazine says no
and a review of then join me
t michael bechtold of house bechtold and
i promise you one thousand nights of
pleasure and twenty thousand nights of
pure terror
give it this man the lanterns after 49
other wives baby i usually have a
horrible pass with t michael beck told
but that team michael bechtel was just
as worse as the other one
hey
what homie lady what ho hi oh what a
rare beauty
i brought with you a gift his sword is
so tiny and he thinks the sword between
his legs must also be tiny shut it
unless i castrate you like one of the
ancillaries sasquate me with that butter
knife that bunny's mean
i am sir bran of house rabbits
i bring you treasures from my land a
thief whose head i disemboweled oh my
god for you for you yes i have removed
it i invite you to be my wife
and allow me to conquer thine dragon
pits
and fill it with many many treasures
[Applause]
if i were to be so fortunate enough to
have you as my queen i promise you a
beautiful castle within walking distance
to a sephora oh that's right i love
something he thinks this man is a maiden
for sure and parking lot must be
horrible at his house me thinking that
if i were a maiden we'd have better luck
with this fair hair beauty
from the gallery we offer you this red
flag
i chop it that red fact i shan't wait
for long okay for my steeds are
hungry
there's no food here someone give this
man the lantern someone feed my horses
already
these are some hungry horses for which
one the chat likes and i'll go through
there
um oh my god this was really hard to
pick from wow i love the idea of writing
a tortoise called
multiple pleasure domes
you didn't give me the amount
i don't know we'll have to ask him i
wasn't here uh but i assumed seven okay
i like a lot of pleasure domes yeah uh
but but i also don't want to be the 50th
wife
you know that's not a bad position being
number five
yeah it's better than being 32 when
there's 50 wives and i also want and i
also just i just
i want to be the number one gizzard not
the 50th if that makes sense you might
like number one the most you might name
them by their numbers um
the last one brought me a gift which
none of them really did oh yeah
movie wow if that is considered a gift
in your house your bar is too low milady
for the gifts that i would give you
would be so fabulous and spoiler alert
this guy lives after being chopped up so
he's not nothing
he's not even dead that's the way to
kill him
you know it was a hard it's hard pick
it's a hard sell
i think brandon's running away with it
who can resist the rabbit who can resist
oh my gosh
well
i guess i have to choose you have to
choose i have to choose you
and i i think i have to go with the last
suitor
wonderful hey what a win not the first
time i've lost to a rabbit if you know
what i'm saying those of you that have
been to an erotic store before
i'm constantly being replaced by rabbits
ah bone horses in the chat for all the
rabbits
i like to see everyone's different
pleasure don't yeah yeah people have
different definitions you know what draw
your pleasure domes tweet them at me at
lulu clemens uh
just send them to my dms i checked them
all uh
great well that uh taught us a lot
about life uh we learned about some of
uh some of the people in the chat we
learned about ourselves team michael was
robbed thank you mr mystery michael
sandman
michael was rob yeah
i think so michael stark if it makes you
guys feel better if he dies i'd
definitely choose michael stock yes
bring in the turtles
to get my own turtle to get a gift and
sephora yeah just for a deal oh i don't
tell you no discount freaky fridays i
probably should have said
ah no it's too late i couldn't tell you
about freaky fridays i'll hold my tongue
for now so many good super chats today
uh the mj2997 saying okay i went from mm
to face paint after my money goobers
that's true that's right we're after
your money buddy alice 2746 saying your
standards are perfect jess don't listen
to him listen to who yeah don't listen
to any of these questions about them
right
uh hugo z in the chat saying can't wait
for that hug between captain marvel and
rogue which will be very interesting if
they're gonna have a rogue in the
marvels maybe and that's actually gets a
powers i don't know i don't know
and the mj2997 also saying i watched
four minutes of morbius on netflix not
good what are you talking about yeah
what does mj stand for maybe joking
what does mk stand for
mighty
mighty
jess
joe young
there we go
we got there we got there what is mj
stanford montgomery jay okay
will there be a contest to win a
mandatory fun mugs there is a contest
hugo z uh to enter the contest you go to
newrockstarsmerch.com
you pay
plus shipping where you see the mug uh
and if you do that you win the contest
and you get a mug congratulations uh and
td jones feeling bad for tommy being
replaced by a rapper i mean sometimes
i'm replaced by a dolphin so i guess
it's not that big of a deal you know
it's i've never seen the ones that have
the little dolphin extension
a lot of attachments go on google
it it does happen uh we want to thank
you all for joining us today on the
break room on our tuesdays apologies to
ander we had a whole android segment
but guess what we got 12 episodes coming
up soon we got three one days we got a
lot of episodes coming soon and word on
the street is they are very good and i'm
very excited about andor and i just want
to hear skarsgard say
zach is also writing the chat a week
from today is our 100th episode oh
that's right thank you zach a week from
today is the 100th episode of the break
room we could literally not do this
without all of you out there watching
we're so excited we're gonna have a
little celebration on that 100th uh
episode day so be sure to tune in next
tuesday but we know you guys tune in
every day so that's not going to be a
problem at all let's make tuesday really
special because our bosses are watching
our bosses are watching they don't watch
any other days special day so please
watch on tuesday
buy a bug while you're at it and tell we
might make a we're nuts about bolts
t-shirts yeah yeah please uh please join
us on our 100th episode and don't tell
philip that the show is still going on i
think he thought he canceled yeah but
we're still here we're going strong and
we've made it to a hundred he thinks
we're just taking an hour break yeah
yeah he literally thinks we're meeting
in the break room he does not realize
that we're doing a show right now uh so
we need your help to keep 100 shots
sounds good i'm going to take 100 shots
of my floor we're taking 100 shots of
water because we need it and you need it
hey if you've liked the show go ahead
and hit that like button if you hated
this show hit that like button uh and be
sure to join us here tomorrow on the
break room check out
newrockstarsmerch.com uh check out our
discord where you can make clips of the
week you can uh chat it up with
everybody uh and make sure most of all
you have a great rest of your tuesday
we'll see you here tomorrow live on the
break room from our break room here are
new rock stars have a great rest of your
tuesday adios
[Music]
strength
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you